so today is a massive day for us here at
the daily wire we are so proud that we
at daily wire fought this thing from the
very start we fought it from day one we
said we were not going to comply and we
didn't and then we spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars to fight this thing
in court we were the first company in
america to file a federal lawsuit
against the biden administration
literally within minutes of them
promulgating the regulation legally we
went to court in the sixth circuit court
of appeals we could not have done that
without those of you who are members and
who have helped make this happen for us
please if you're not a member consider
joining up today and helping us fight
because that's what we do here at daily
wire head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe for today only promo code
winning it gets you 40 off an entire
year's membership so you can support us
all year long we have amazing content
but you're really helping the cause more
than anything else dailywire.com
subscribe use promo code winning because
we're going to keep on winning to get 40
off that annual membership the supreme
court ruled 6-3 yesterday that joe
biden's vaccine mandate via osha was
wildly unconstitutional because as it
turns out it is wildly unconstitutional
it is a violation of the separation of
powers
it is a violation of the enabling
act of the of the
original body itself osha the
occupational safety and health safety
and health administration
and it was being used as a cudgel by the
executive branch of the government to
simply end around the constitutional
process of working through a legislature
see here in the united states there's
this thing called the constitution the
constitution mandates that if you're
going to effectuate a major policy you
need to go through this thing called the
legislature the legislature is in its
turn comprised of two separate bodies
the house of representatives which is a
portion according to population and the
senate of the united states in which
each state gets two senators i know this
is really basic stuff but apparently
people on the left need to hear this the
new republic today
the new republic
not even kidding you they tweeted out
today the new republic which is supposed
to be a sophisticated liberal magazine
quote the real supreme court ruling
appears to be this the biden
administration can only try new
solutions to new problems if it runs
them through a gerrymandered house and a
filibuster friendly senate first oh you
mean you can only do things that you
don't have the authority to do if you
are given that authority by the congress
of the united states who could have
suspected such a thing except for
everyone who has ever read the
constitution of the united states it's
just unbelievable okay so the supreme
court ruled 6-3 in favor of getting rid
of joe biden's vax mandate and the
language was pretty strong here we're
going to go through it
and as we do i want you to remember that
there were three justices on the other
side briar kagan sotomayor and those
three justices on the other side rule
that the occupational safety and health
administration with no actual statutory
authority
could force 100 million americans to
vaccinate because they had jobs
that is what the left of the court said
that an obscure agency
that generally you have no interface
with
that obscure agency granted power by an
act in the 70s
suddenly had the authority to decide
whether you had to vaccinate whether or
not you had natural immunity or
religious objection or some sort of
existing condition that prevented you
from getting the vaccine safely that you
had to vaccinate or lose your job three
justices on the supreme court said that
that was totally fine
and uh if if hillary clinton had been
elected in 2016 that would have been
five or six justices on the supreme
court of the united states because
remember president trump got three picks
all three voted the right way in this
particular case all right so here's what
the court ruled yesterday the secretary
of labor acting through the occupational
safety and health administration
recently enacted a vaccine mandate for
much of the nation's workforce
the mandate which employers must enforce
applies to roughly 84 million workers
covering virtually all employers with at
least 100 employees it requires that
government workers receive a coveted 19
vaccine it preempts contrary state laws
the only exception is for workers who
obtain a medical test each week at their
own expense and on their own time and
also wear a mask each workday osha has
never before imposed such a mandate nor
has congress indeed although congress
has enacted significant legislation
addressing the kova 19 pandemic it has
declined to enact any measure similar to
what osha has promulgated here
many states businesses and non-profit
organizations challenged osha's rule in
courts of appeals across the country the
fifth circuit initially entered a stay
but when the cases were consolidated
before the sixth circuit that court
lifted the stay and allowed osha's rule
to take effect
applicants now seek emergency relief
from this court arguing osha's mandate
exceeds its statutory authority and is
otherwise unlawful agreeing that
applicants are likely to prevail we
grant their applications and stay the
rule remember there's a preliminary
injunction because the rule didn't even
go into fact
so the supreme court then goes through
the history of the occupational safety
and health act which was created in 1970
the act created osha the occupational
safety and health administration which
is part of the department of labor and
under the supervision of its secretary
as its name suggests osha is tasked with
ensuring occupational safety that is
safe and helpful working conditions
it does so by enforcing occupational
safety and health standards promulgated
by the secretary
such standards must be reasonably
necessary or appropriate to provide safe
or helpful employment
it must also be developed using a
rigorous process that includes notice
comment and an opportunity for a public
hearing however there's an exception
you're allowed to also promulgate
emergency temporary standards such
standards may take immediate effect upon
publication in the federal register this
is only permissible in extremely narrow
circumstances
it's only been used nine times before
this emergency authority six of those
times it was challenged in court only
one of those was upheld in full
okay so the supreme court goes through
the process by which the biden
administration created this osha rule
and and the supreme court
then points out
that applicants are likely to succeed on
the merits of their claim that the
secretary lacked authority to impose the
mandate administrative agencies are
creatures of statute they accordingly
possess only the authority congress has
provided right congress says that osha
can do x osha cannot do x y and z osha
can only do x and if ocean proclaims
that z is part of x osha has exceeded
its mandate under its enabling act
the secretary has ordered 84 million
americans to either obtain a coven-19
vaccine or undergo weekly medical
testing at their own expense this is no
everyday exercise of federal power it is
instead a significant encroachment into
the lives and health of a vast number of
employees
this is the supreme court we expect
congress to speak clearly when
authorizing an agency to exercise powers
of vast economic and political
significance there can be little doubt
that ocean's mandate qualifies as an
exercise of such authority the question
then is whether the act plainly
authorizes the secretary's mandate it
does not the act empowers the secretary
to set workplace safety standards not
broad public health measures
no provision of the act addresses public
health more generally which falls
outside of osha's sphere of expertise so
in other words
it is true that covert 19 is a threat
inside the workplace it is also a threat
outside the workplace and everywhere
else that human beings congregate
and as the supreme court is about to say
just because you have a job doesn't mean
that the court can now do that osha
cannot do whatever it wants to you so
for example
osha could not promulgate a rule saying
that obesity is a serious problem at the
workplace because there are people at
the workplace and obesity is a problem
therefore it is a serious workplace
problem therefore you're not allowed to
eat fatty foods at your workplace via
osha via osha regulation there's nothing
that would allow that sort of thing the
descent protest we are imposing a limit
found no place in the governing statute
not so says the supreme court it is the
text of the agency's organic act that
repeatedly makes clear that osha is
charged with regulating occupational
hazards and the safety and health of
employees the solicitor general does not
dispute that osha is limited to
regulating work-related dangers she
instead argues the risk of contracting
covenant 19 qualifies as such a danger
we cannot agree although covet 19 is a
risk that occurs in many workplaces it
is not an occupational hazard in most
clover 19 canon does spread at home in
schools during sporting events
everywhere else people gather that kind
of universal risk is no different from
the day-to-day dangers that all face
from crime air pollution or any number
of communicable diseases
permitting osha to regulate the hazards
of daily life simply because most
americans have jobs and face those same
risks while on the clock would
significantly expand osha's regulatory
authority without clear congressional
authorization
the dissent says the supreme court
contends that osha's mandate is
comparable to a fire or sanitation
regulation imposed by the agency but a
vaccine mandate is strikingly unlike the
workplace regulations that osha has
typically imposed a vaccination after
all cannot be undone at the end of the
workday
contrary to the descent's contention
imposing a vaccine mandate on 84 million
americans in response to a worldwide
pandemic is simply not part of what the
agency was built for
that is not to say osha lacks authority
to regulate occupation-specific risks
related to covet-19 where the virus
poses a special danger because of the
particular features of an employee's job
or workplace targeted regulations are
plainly permissible we don't doubt for
example that osha could regulate
researchers who work with kovi 19.
osha could regulate risks associated
with working in particularly crowded or
cramped environments but the danger
present in such workplaces differs in
both degree and kind from the everyday
risk of contracting coca-19 that all
phase
then they point out
that the senate of the united states
actually voted against greenlighting
exactly this procedure there was a
procedural vote that was brought up
before the senate and the senate
symbolically said we don't like this
regulation which is a pretty good
indicator congress does not mean to
grant this sort of authority to osha
the supreme court says the equities do
not justify withholding interim relief
we're told by the states and the
employers that osha's mandate will force
them to incur billions of dollars in
unrecoverable compliance costs and will
cause hundreds of thousands of employees
to leave their jobs
for its part the federal government says
the mandate will save over 6 500 lives
and prevent hundreds of thousands of
hospitalization
the supreme court says it is not our
role to waste such trade-offs in our
system of government that is the
responsibility of those chosen by the
people through the democratic process
although congress has indisputably given
osha the power to regulate occupational
dangers it has not given that agency the
power to regulate public health more
broadly
requiring the vaccination of 84 million
americans simply because they have jobs
certainly falls in the latter category
okay so that is the majority supreme
court opinion 6-3 then
there is also the concurrence when the
concurrence goes further this is from
gorsuch thomas and alito we'll get to
that in just one second because it makes
some pretty important points about the
legislative branch and why we still need
a legislative branch in the united
states
this really was a clash of massive ideas
as to the future of the country if this
had gone the other way it would
essentially spell the end truly of
anything remotely like the
constitutional structure in the united
states
essentially we'd be living under full
administrative fiat at the behest of the
wild left
green lit by justices on the supreme
court if this is going the other way on
to the concurrence in this case this is
gorsuch thomas and alito
they say the central question we face
today is who decides no one doubts that
the covet 19 pandemic has posed
challenges for every american or that
our state local and national governments
all have roles to play in combating the
disease the only question is whether an
administrative agency in washington one
charged with overseeing workplace safety
may mandate the vaccination or regular
testing of 84 million people or whether
as 27 states before us submit that work
belongs to state and local governments
across the country and the people's
elected representatives in congress this
court is not a public health authority
but it is charged with resolving
disputes about which authorities possess
the power to make the laws that govern
us under the constitution and the laws
of the land
and essentially what they say is state
and local governments have extraordinary
plenary authority when it comes to
regulation of health this is not true of
the federal government the federal
government's powers are not general but
limited and divided say the three
concurring justices not only must the
federal government properly invoke a
constitutionally enumerated source of
authority to regulate in this area or
any other it must also act consistently
with the constitution's separation of
powers
and when it comes to that obligation
this court has established at least one
firm rule we expect congress to speak
clearly if it wishes to assign to an
executive agency decisions of vast
economic and political significance
we sometimes call this the major
questions doctrine osha's mandate fails
that doctrine's test the agency claims
the power to force 84 million americans
to receive a vaccine or undergo regular
testing by any measure that is a claim
of power to resolve a question of vast
national significance yet congress has
nowhere clearly assigned so much power
to osha approximately two years have
passed since the pandemic began vaccines
have been available for more than a year
over that span congress has adopted
several major pieces of legislation
aimed at combating kovit 19. it seems
too that the agency pursued its
regulatory initiative only as a
legislative workaround okay what's
hilarious about that particular note
right there which is that osha created
this because they couldn't get it done
in the legislature
is that ron clayne literally tweeted
that joe biden's chief of staff tweeted
that and then that tweet was cited as
evidenced by the concurrence in this
case saying you guys can't do that it
violates the constitutional structure so
well done by an administration i mean
just admitted what you were doing and
the court caught you
what is osha's reply it directs us to 29
usc u.s code section 655 c1 in that
statutory subsection says the
concurrence congress authorized osha to
issue emergency regulations upon
determining that employees are exposed
to grave danger from exposure to
substances or agents determined to be
toxic or physically harmful and that
such emergency standards are necessary
to protect employees from such danger
according to the agency this provision
supplies with almost unlimited
discretion to mandate new nationwide
rules in response to the pandemic so
long as those rules are reasonably
related to workplace safety the court
rightly applies the major questions
doctrine and concludes that this lone
statutory subsection does not clearly
authorize osha's mandate
that section was not adopted in response
to the pandemic but 50 years ago at the
time of osha's creation since then osha
has relied on it to issue only
comparatively modest rules addressing
dangers uniquely prevalent inside the
workplace like asbestos and rare
chemicals
as the agency itself explained to the
federal court less than two years ago
the statute does not authorize osha to
issue sweeping health standards that
affect workers lives outside the
workplace but that is exactly what they
are trying to do right now
the concurrence continues they say why
does the major questions doctrine matter
it ensures the national government's
power to make the laws that govern us
remains or article one of the
constitution says it belongs with the
people's elected representatives if
administrative agencies seek to regulate
the daily lives and liberties of
millions of americans the doctrine says
they must at least be able to trace that
power to a clear grant of authority from
congress
and then the court continues
say in this respect the major questions
doctrine is closely related to what is
sometimes called the non-delegation
doctrine indeed for decades courts have
cited the non-delegation doctrine as a
reason to apply the major questions
doctrine essentially the non-delegation
doctrine says the legislative branch of
the government cannot just say
cannot pass a law saying to the
executive branch do whatever you want
right that is a delegation of powers
that cannot delegate
and so the way you can tell if the
non-delegation doctrine has been
violated is if there are major questions
that have been left wildly open to the
interpretation of executive branch
agencies
say the concurrences the non-delegation
doctrine ensures democratic
accountability by by preventing congress
from intentionally delegating its
legislative powers to unelected
officials
sometimes lawmakers may be tempted to
delegate power to agencies to reduce the
degree to which they will be held
accountable
if congress could hand off all
legislative powers to unelected agency
officials it would dash the whole scheme
of our constitution
the major questions doctrine serves a
similar function by guarding against
unintentional oblique or otherwise
unlikely delegations of the legislative
power sometimes there's ambiguity and
agencies take advantage for example
whichever the doctrine the point is the
same both serve to prevent government by
bureaucracy supplanting government by
the people
and both hold their lessons for today's
case is the concurrence
on the one hand osha claims the power to
issue a nationwide mandate on a major
question but can't trace its authority
to do so to any clear congressional
mandate on the other hand if the
statutory subsection the agency cites
really did endow osha with that power
that law would likely constitute an
unconstitutional delegation of
legislative authority
under osha's reading the law would
afford it almost unlimited discretion
and this is the key point and this is
the key point that the concurrence is
making
the legislature still exists and because
the legislature still exists and ought
to exist osha does not have this
authority if congress wants to pass a
law like this it actually has to make
the case that it want that it's going to
pass the law like this
okay so in a second we will get to the
descent because to me the descents in
this case are spine chilling they really
are they should chill your blood
at first gen zaki came out yesterday
posted the decision from the white house
she says don't don't worry joe biden is
still going to encourage businesses to
implement the vacuum and here's the
thing if a business chooses to implement
that vax mandate that is now on the
business that business no longer gets to
blame joe biden or the federal
government
this also gives the lie to a lot of a
lot of businesses that were saying we're
going to preemptively do this under the
assumption that it was going to be
greenlit by the supreme court
now you didn't have to you guys didn't
have to you could have stood up for your
employees
here's jen saki saying they're going to
encourage businesses to continue this
anyway
the sen the the the supreme court's
decision on the osha mandate essentially
means that in the patent this pandemic
is up to individual employers to
determine whether their workplaces will
be safe for employees and whether their
businesses will be safe for consumers uh
so president biden you'll see this in
his statement uh will be calling on and
will continue to call on businesses to
immediately join these those who have
already stepped up including one-third
of fortune 100 companies to institute
vaccination requirements to protect
their workers
customers and communities okay so they
can encourage as much as they want but
that's not what they were attempting to
do they were attempting to destroy
businesses that refused to comply
they were literally threatening
businesses with 14 000 fines for every
unintentional violation and one hundred
and forty thousand dollar fines for
every intentional violation they would
have bankrupted our company inside of a
week that was their goal that was their
explicit goal here and it wasn't to shut
down the virus because they can't do
that not with omicron it was to control
that's all they care about
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang